all right get ready for youtube star
latoya ali
aka latoya forever she's got over 1.4
million subscribers
and now she's bringing the heat to
hotlanta word on the street
is that you this season will be joining
the real housewives of atlanta
oh my gosh it's just been an experience
it's spicy are you stirring the pot
young lady maybe just a little bit
yes sad because you know i keep it real
the youtube star is also keeping it real
when it comes to her skin care
we teamed up with latoya and delay to
keep your skin beautiful all season long
my followers are like latoya what do you
use how is your skin so
smooth and soft and i always recommend
the ole ultra rich
hydrating moisturizer it has shea butter
in it
and it keeps my skin luxurious and it's
not greasy
at all and i also use the olay retinol
24 max
every single night and it keeps my skin
looking smooth and so
bright and you can purchase it at cvs or
you can go to the website which is
cvs.com
honey it's going to give us that glow
i'll have what you're having that's that
natural glow
okay olay